listen you ain't tough no i'm not gonna
listen to you you're not my
mother if we were i would if i was your
mother
ladies oh yeah i would change bring it
on
during part two of the tell-all angela
went
off on asuelu's sister tammy for
one straight minute i love you andrew
i don't think her dad because your dad
her dad should have done with
us and made
it was literally a minute she smoked
every bit of her mind meanwhile asuelu
he couldn't handle all of the criticism
coming his way
so he walked off the tell-all leaving
kalani there
in tears to make matters worse
when she went to go look for him he was
nowhere to be found
asuelu took his keys and left the house
did she get weenie
i'm sorry but he is a weenie debbie
really a weenie all right
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
part two of the tell all revealed new
shocking
yet not so shocking details about
colt and vanessa's relationship i cheat
on jess with vanessa
plus sinjin admitted if he's willing to
put down the alcohol
to be with tanya would you ultimately
give up drinking to save your marriage
no we'll get into that in just a few
but first let's kick it off with what
caused
angela to get into it with tammy
at the top of the episode asuelu broke
down in tears
as he confronted his mom about this
statement
she made i'm sorry clanny i don't care
about the kids
i want to take back my son to someone i
wish you
don't say that to my wife
well mom was mad as well mama's mad and
she he she ended up saying i don't care
if she's mad or whatever i don't care
it's my kids come on tammy being mad has
never
been a good excuse for being
disrespectful it wasn't long before she
was questioned
about why she felt the need to try to
fight kalani
i got so mad because she was starting to
walk away while we're
trying to talk about the situation about
us
helping helping us back home but she
just walked away so it makes me mad that
she just
that wasn't really talking at that point
once it gets heated
like why would she stand there and take
that from the both of you
fellini why you have to be involved
colleen what do you have to do because
i'm sitting here we're on a towel
i will beat you up too oh
i'll give you my address yeah i'll send
i'll text you to my address right now
okay so after this little back and forth
everyone started to chime in on the
situation
i think little sister over there in the
corner should go home back to wherever
she came from and if her and her mother
can't afford to live here
then they need to go back to samoa
that's my turn don't tell me what to do
andre surprisingly came in as
the voice of reason here telling tammy
that
using threats isn't the way to go
i mean the visual is not the proper
timing not a classy lady
yeah you you should not do that for
money
but once angela got in the ring
it was pretty much over you sat here and
bullied all these ladies on here well
bully me
bring it on ladies and gentlemen listen
no no
[Music]
where is michael michael michael is
somewhere being quiet right now
that's what he's doing well on a serious
note
besides all of the threats angela
said what we've all been thinking
melanie's the runner of that house
she takes care of two kids she sends
y'all money what she can afford
i wouldn't say the way you are
disrespectful
you always feel like
and make him grow up he
i mean thankfully for tammy this was
all virtual you could see ashwalu was
visibly getting upset
and as the conversation continued it got
worse
kalani opened her heart about feeling
torn
when it comes to their marriage she got
really emotional
and asuelu's lack of support right then
and there
just irritated her mom lisa he's just
sitting there stoic
nothing it's just disgusting to me
so now i'm angry looking at him giving
nothing i know that this isn't how she
wanted things to be
but it takes more than one person to
make something work
again
point proven as i mentioned earlier
asuelu left the house kalani
later revealed that he also blocked her
number is that like a consistent thing
with he does
yeah anytime we get into any little
petty argument he blocks my numbers
i know she has to be drained
lesson for all of us if you are the only
one putting in effort
and you see that the bad times are
overriding the good
it's time to go alright moving on to
colt
who admitted he cheated on jess with
vanessa
after he came back from brazil it's not
just when he's come back to brazil he's
[ __ ] me with vanessa
since he's meet me you know about love
you know about family you know about
nothing because you're weird you're
disgusting and she's still married right
yeah so i separated i haven't seen him
in over a year
so what's a big deal shut up you want a
heart larissa had a boyfriend before she
was
divorced so what's the problem speaking
of larissa
colt also confessed to having an
emotional affair
with vanessa while he was married to her
colt said that you and he
had an emotional affair what did that
mean
i mean we were both in bad marriages and
uh
it just we just talked about it
i mean larissa was
she knew exactly what she was doing i
found the test
from someone on his phone
that i truly believe is vanessa saying
i'm done i'm tired to waiting hi
so i truly believe he's [ __ ] me from
the beginning with vanessa
so you're probably wondering why won't
colt and vanessa
just be together right well we know that
colt wants to be in a relationship with
her
but she's not interested in making it
official
finally vanessa explained why
i love cole as a best friend but i don't
exactly
i wouldn't trust him as a boyfriend and
the biggest reason you would not
trust colt is what uh
i just feel like he doesn't know what he
wants right now so he kind of
goes from girl to girl to girls seeing
like maybe
maybe this is what i'm looking for now
not really maybe this one no not really
so i need him to be sure what he wants
right now
i get it but vanessa you can't say that
and then enable colt's cheating behavior
sean even asked her if she felt like it
was necessary to apologize to jess
for sleeping with colt while they were
in a relationship
no all she did was
talk about me i don't feel bad woman
supports men likes what what water woman
is terrible too look like him okay so i
think he went
called this this every dishwater because
it's too terrible pierce
don't act like a victim you have a life
miserable you're terrible says the
girl calling me and all this yeah
go
well that was the end of all of that
interestingly enough on part three of
the tell-all
we meet jess's new man
look my yoki grades
the man off my dream who is
this man i can't wait to see
all right well finally we have sinjin
who said he's not willing to give up
drinking
to save his marriage to tanya how long
are you willing to
put up with his drinking i mean if it
just keeps going the way it
is how long are you willing to do that
not long and he knows that so to be very
honest you know
i will not uh be giving up drinking
probably my whole entire life
i enjoy a copy i enjoy the beverage i
enjoy the time with it
and if that bug's hurt that just means i
must get somebody who doesn't
have an alcoholic
i hate talking sinjin's friends are
hilarious well when it comes to these
two
i'm going to end it here with this last
question that sean
asked which put everything into
perspective
sentient do you believe that if you had
not
gotten married at the time you did
where would your relationship be
today i think um
if we never got married i think we would
have been broken up yeah
so a piece of paper at this point
is keeping them together
all right well coming up on part three
of the tell-all
angela threatens to end her marriage to
michael
where do we go from here to the
courthouse
and eric gets grilled about meeting up
with colt
and talking about larissa's intimacy did
you bad mouth larissa to cult
well it depends what you consider bad
malfunction go on
say yes or no
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because as usual we are covering it all
stay safe i'll see you next time